hier soir elle les parlementaires ont
donné leur feu vert au nouveau délit dit
de séparatisme il s'agit de l'article iv
de ce texte qui prévoit est cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et 75 mille euros
damende pour toute personne menaçant
violentant où intimidant un élu ou un
agent à du service public dans le but de
se soustraire aux règles du service
public ils ont aussi ils sont aussi un
tombés d'accord sur un délit d' entrave
à la fonction d'enseignant une
disposition qui fait suite à
l'assassinât de samuel pâti en octobre
dernier du côté des débats ils ont
parfois été à vie fin cette semaine on
se souvient türk is it war accompagné à
d'une motion de rejet contre ce texte de
la part de jean luc mélenchon à lundi
dernier en milieu de semaine ce sont là
les élus républicains à qui on est et a
critiqué pour avoir présenté à des
amendements à sur le port du voile des
amendements qui ont été rejetées et puis
sachez acquis hier dans un rapport rendu
public la commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme a
vivement a critiqué ce projet de loi un
texte qui selon elle contient des
mesures est disproportionnée qui portent
atteinte aux libertés fondamentales
fin de citation